good morning Hank and welcome to cooking
with John the show where we make and eat
disgusting things in our last episode
you'll no doubt remember I made and ate
a blender I've mcdonald's happy meal
today we're going to eat the nutritional
equivalent of some Carl's jr. specialty
burger but instead of eating the burger
itself we're going to eat its
constituent parts so fat corn syrup salt
and of course protein I got this
strawberry flavored protein because it
was cheaper so that will probably be a
regret of mine also of course a
hamburger bun I got the wheat buns
because you know I'm watching my figure
so we're gonna have a quarter cup of
pure unadulterated Crisco fat that is
one teaspoon of high fructose corn syrup
in the form of Mrs Butterworth
and we're gonna have 1 teaspoon salt and
2 scoops of soy protein strawberry
flavored now we're gonna turn it on and
we're gonna turn this into a delicious
smush do you think it's gonna be better
or worse than the blender iced happy
meal um better really yeah just
consistency wise if one horizon even was
the worst event of my life I think
having the bun yeah as a like familiar
element right will help it considerably
it's just a sandwich you know just a fat
sandwich I kind of have a new fear
what's your new fear like you think I'm
gonna like it and I'm gonna be like baby
they make me a fat sandwich strawberry
flavored please
time for the sexy close-up Hank look at
that beautiful fat sandwich alright Hank
I'm going to eat this
describe it John it's fine unfortunately
it's really good the strawberry flavor
is amazing and it's salty and sugary and
fatty mmm okay I'm about halfway through
my uh my burger and it is starting to
taste pretty bad that first bite was
delicious and now I feel kind of sick
but I'm just powered through
it's really nasty now it's really nasty
now I'm just gonna freeze it right there
Hank because a lot of young people watch
our videos and they don't need to see a
31 year old man having what is known in
competitive eating circles as a reversal
of fortune back to it oh I love you
nerdfighters
I did it just like regular fast food the
first couple bites were delicious and
then it became progressively grosser and
then I vomited and then I managed to
continue eating to pay for their penance
I will answer the first three hundred
and seventeen questions asked in
comments particularly if they're at the
Ning Hank I'll see you tomorrow